this is a first viewing of Max Payne uh
I've got a cup of Cheers
we actually played this game when it
first came out yeah how long ago was it
yeah early 2000s I think so we got
really examine we heard a movie was
coming out cuz it's like Oh awesome like
that's a great you could so easily see
that becoming a movie and then the
apparently sucked like it sucked my
heart and then that went through the
Hollywood homogenizer and yeah is this I
remember looking good like visually it
seemed like oh that this will be alright
so here it is our viewing of next pain
you know there is nothing funnier to me
than studio logos and shitty films
because it's so proudly proclaiming to
the universe this is garbage it also
could be some of the best effects we see
in the movie we don't know that's true I
could feel the dead reaching up to
welcome me as one of their own so far it
seems like it's on the right track
it means game a film the waters are some
of the few films nowadays they can get
away with some time earlier like it's
like the only genre where I allow that
I'm like no that's okay this is the cold
case office as was already established
in the establishing shot where it said
cold case unit on the sign Keith used
kids leads
it's a szeliga very Chicago dad Max
Payne day Max Payne there you know him
max paying everybody filing papers away
action cabinets yeah the way he gotten
their reversi trips
there's nobody throw newspapers the way
I mean that's like the one litter that's
everywhere in dark cities
I hope you not notice dropping that it's
not like a common thing made a very loud
clink pawned it up on 128 two hours ago
that's Doug he was doing with you well
yes it's true that is Macaulay Culkin
following you it's kind of Walberg at
his most Matt Damon yes I do come it's
this is very like Bourne Identity
this movie is obsessed with signs yes
Rosco Street cold-case unit you know
because the game was very comic location
had the low flocks with riding on it
maybe that's their like version of that
the david days of actually all this
stuff is still around
Travis Prince I am sploshing see how I
destroy the spellcheck with that one
pretty tasty fine I'll leave this scene
so I don't have to pretend to know
Russian with the exception of Black Swan
have you ever seen Mila Kunis play the
badass convincingly oh dear god no she's
kind of adorable
he's ever been isn't that Jim Beam
commercial she does where she's like
kick of the cast he's like yeah this
bitch is mine and that's just more cuz
she's next to alcohol and that's just
now immediately cool I like bourbon and
I like women and yeah look it was snow
bow movie isn't giving us it's pretty
standard so yeah I'm surprised at how
standard it is I was expecting kind of a
little worse yeah I mean people hate it
so much
hey so um yeah I wanted to talk can you
please close your legs I just wanted to
like you know just sit there half-naked
in Ewoks in what
what no this is like somebody's demo
real for how they can make a better
movie this is the demo for the Max Payne
movie yeah this is all just a series of
really cool-looking shots I love the
cinematography but like no story or
anything going on it's like here's some
more cool looking shots here's kind of a
sex scene but we didn't film the rest of
it here's kind of that glance scene you
have in every movie here yeah every
scene you get in every movie but no
payoff to it it means that with your
follow to an unsolved murders I don't
have much hope for that girl in the
alley so in the game as the shade as it
was where you just sucked in immediately
yeah like this is really boring well we
didn't see the murder whose wife yeah I
remember the game right that's update
not like no Penelope early come on max I
can't walk after you we're doing the gun
pointing while I'm looking around seeing
that's in every movie like this you're
noticing Phil Dewar's the air
conditioning is never all the way on
it's like at the slowest setting where
you ain't getting any air at all because
you need to have shadows accentuating
yeah it's film noir number one man that
lights got a huge reverb
some shout again this mist woke up with
a popsicle say in my mouth
I missed so game drums humor for you
guys nobody watches us watches games
done it'll be a cold day in hell before
we ever work with that egoraptor who is
that guy I don't know I'm not even in
focus the DP just was a figure it's like
fuck it this movie's gonna suck I'm not
literally a script for a Steven Seagal
movie I'm not putting my a material on
this that's the number one thing missing
there's no humor in this it definitely
needs more dick justice ya shoulda just
change max Payne's name - dick justice
like the game wasn't a comedy but
definitely had limey dick moments yeah
the story was stupid simple it was the
Punisher I mean that's basically what
the story was it was just the Punisher
how in that game you take something
that's stupid simple and over
complicated to this degree
oh but like blow some shit up already
both conversations here
talkity-talk talk I will find you -
Cabrio that's what I want I want Mark
Wahlberg from The Departed to shoot this
Mark Wahlberg by me I get max paynt in
the game I felt like they knew like no
we know we're doing these exactly
whoa about make them big make them fun
like there's no fun to them make my
kinda yeah detective Max Payne okay the
snow is winning me over I'm not gonna
lie just the way it's always beautifully
it's very homework movie yeah you are
flicks kind of looking I'm kind of
loving it like that's more what the
movie needs to be he's your friend I
guess if I had nickel for every cop and
of Mark Twain Boston you just said the
magic word this whole performance is
just this I'm not gonna lie I am more
interested in what that woman in the
background is working on yeah I get
these potato flakes out you're gonna
freeze to death don't you come inside
it's snowing inside - it's not it will
take a nice Drive it's snowing in my car
the amount
snow they're getting in this week like
you should be covering the buildings
cancer probably spotted my bag yes my
this and it's yours too late to club so
not intimidating I like her too I feel
like you're in a lot of stuff it's just
a badass role it never works
yeah like he's on his knees that he's
almost the same height is perfect that's
this kind of like Mila Kunis hate and
I'm not a dad but she I don't say this
she's one of the most miscast people
I've ever seen it can be very funny she
can be very dramatic gonna she's not a
badass so we got this kind of badass oh
[Music]
you know what happened to her this must
have come out with Batman Begins came
out cuz they're doing that same stupid
shaky a fag like with a scarecrow hat or
so when the music has it like Zimmer II
yeah Wow all we're missing is a you know
what the scenes gonna be the second it
starts yeah like okay he's seeing shit
he's gonna jump off Valkyries fly over
the battlefield picking out the
righteous dead I want this guy's bores
I'm just like oh my god a character I'm
listening to know if he's looking for
something then God wants to stay he did
yeah if I walked into this movie and
didn't read any reviews right there just
going off to the feathers based on the
game I find will walked out by now I've
been like there is nothing to this yeah
caught and finally we have an action
sequence during the moment we know he's
gonna get out final way to see going
he's going full happening this happening
face going on come on shouted good Kelly
you got a shout no it's from the game
it's from every cliche detective story
come on yeah I just realized why he
didn't shout no cuz if he did it he know
someone in your office it's a detective
the world's greatest detective
please be Batman please be Batman please
we've been all tell me about what
Michelle was working on I can tell you
right now Bam Bam Bam action sequence
jump out the window
it's slow-mo the 360 camera or we could
sit around talk yeah bullet I'm talking
my nerves course sure god he finally
killed some people I need a new hat no
man how are we not getting this guy this
would be pretty easy that's what this is
about a drunk
Elmo so if I can give you Pro passing
the snow fort won't protect me
Oklahoma Oklahoma we know we belong to
the land but let we belong to his grass
okay seriously come on I know why
there's so half-hour left it's gonna be
you know it's amazing cuz this is where
the movie started out I feel like I've
learned so little I don't know shit
about him yeah oh my god I got it so
right where we started and his wife died
there's some bad guys here Mila Kunis is
in this for some reason which I think
all of that you could have guessed he
just say it's like yeah how'd it get her
I don't know his family was kids you
like a watch one giant long extended
trailer what did you forget what no they
needed a sign like everything else it
says he did it I have the poorly
rendered POW commands are just flipping
channels and walking into the movie
right now I think I started left behind
man I was like five cliches what the
hell is going on what my team here what
authority do you get me out of this
picture he's not dead he's here bullshit
okay I believe you
this is so great because we really knew
their relationship our connection
like gunfire action like not a CGI
fuckfest Rob this this is clearly Max
Payne I mean look at it don't you
remember this from the gate fire and
angels flying around him I mean that
those Max Payne is all about
next would be telling me there weren't
Nazis in the cracker get over here so we
can be the thumbnail of an Amazon show
Ned and the high castle
[Laughter]
so the villainous doesn't even like oh
my god this movie can have a cool I
think if she just comes up like with the
machine guys either like shoulder pads
suit it just goes jump jump jump
make sure there isn't a sequel because
that really good nothing wow just wow he
started off kind of alright I was in it
for about 10 minutes and then it's just
like doomed it's about 10 minutes in my
eyes made this look sorry it's not that
bad and just slowly like oh it doesn't
really go anywhere except exactly where
you think it's gonna go with nothing
added on to it it doesn't really pick up
what was cool about the game or why
people liked the game I mean it's one of
those were honestly if you just kind of
deal with the game did it be fine I mean
I don't know why they like just made it
so much both more complicated and
somehow dumber that so many people
really hated this movie that I thought
maybe it was gonna be like really
insulting Lee like goofy over the Rob
crazy but and it wasn't it was just so
boring which is kind of worse that's
just such a worse offense that you can
do just stupid don't have much else
Minds drained in the life yeah I mean
just dream the color and the life I mean
nothing ah so that's it'd be fun to get
review out of that it was a maximum
amount of pain yes doesn't chew truth in
advertising so that's it
No
you